et où
[Musique]
implanet harakis est tellement belle
quand le soleil est bas
on peut alors voir sur le sable les peas
qui tourbillonne au gré du vent
les étrangers ravages notaires sont nos
yeux
je n'ai toujours connu que leur cruauté
envers le peuple
qu'adviendra-t-il de notre monde
[Musique]
aulas et d'alcan je peux te faire
confiance oui toujours tu le sais j'ai
fait des rêves dernièrement leur ai vu
une fille sur harakis je ne sais pas ce
que ça signifie les rêves font de bonnes
histoires mais le plus important se
passe quand on est ailier rien toi tu as
pris du muscle tu crois non
nous sommes la maison a three nul appel
ne saurait rester sans réponse
nulle confiance ne saurait être trahie
sourit kearney est ce que je fais mon
seigneur l'empereur nous demande
d'apporter l'a fait sur harakis la
maison atréides accepte
je connais
quelque chose s'éveille dans leur esprit
tu dois affronter tes peurs
viens avec moi
doit être prêt
t'as jamais rencontré les reconnaît et
sont pas humains ce sont des brutes
sanguinaires
le fils du duc est trop clairvoyant
tu n'es pas moi tuez les tous
judiciaire
jacques dictant les douze appareils
apple
c'est une extermination en règle
il élimine les proches les uns après les
autres
4 comme des lions
r et si je n'étais pas l'avenir de la
maison atrides
un grand homme ne cherche pas à diviser
il est appelé à diriger
la réponse est non
tu seras toujours ce qu'il ya de plus
important pour moi
mon fils
[Applaudissements]
s'il doit m'arriver malades
protégerait vous notre fils je serai
prête à donner une vie
on devra s'unir si on veut survivre
ton destin t'appelle
[Applaudissements]
gamer